Let us solve some tasks in order of action, but in order to save time I will solve every second example
I will do these tasks here:
We start with 1b
1b here
There are 2 plus 7 by 11 minus 12 divided by 3
Just remember that first is what you have in brackets.
braces
So you have your braces-- Let me write them this way.
Your highest priority will be brackets,
after that, the gradation,
then multiplication and division and then
addition and subtraction
Let us remember this and get caught up
with the sequence of operations
For order - no brackets here,
there is no degree, so the priority goes to multiplication
and division.
You can watch this in the following way
We do our multiplication before we make a collection or
subtract and do our division before
to perform any collection or subtraction
Task 1b is precisely that
brackets are just to confirm your intention,
that I will accomplish my multiplication and division
before I do the collection and subtraction.
So 7 by 11 is 77, then 12 divided by 3 is 4
And the rest of the task was 2 plus that thing, which is 77, minus that.
And here, since everything is gathering or subtracting,
let's just go from left to right.
2 plus 77 is 79, minus 4 is equal to 75
So 1b is equal to 75
Let us decide 1d
This is a pleasantly complicated task.
So 1d.
You see 2 by 3 plus 2 minus 1
Close the two brackets, all on 4 minus 6 plus 2
minus 3 minus 5
Let's see if we can do that a little.
As we have said, brackets have the highest priority.
So let's fix the brackets first. 2 minus 1.
2 minus 1 is only 1.
3 minus 5
This makes minus 2 or, I have to say, negative 2.
6 plus 2 is 8.
Now let's keep looking at the brackets to see
where can we simplify things
We have these braces here
So 3 plus 1 will now be equal to 4
Actually, let me transcribe this.
We get 2 across this expression, 3 plus 1, that's 2 in 4.
That, right there, is 4.
All this on 4 minus 8, this is negative 4.
This is exactly what is negative here 4.
And then minus this negative 2.
So minus negative 2.
2 at 4 e 8, so all this is simplified to - minus
from negative is exactly plus,
the negatives are destroyed.
Thus, the whole is simplified to 8 divided by a negative of 4,
which is negative 2, plus 2
.
Which is equal to 0.
So this big, complicated thing is simplified to 0.
Now let's solve 2b
2b.
Let me clear a little space here.
I will leave the operations priorities there.
Let me delete that, and let me wipe it out
Okay, 2b
2b.
Calculate the following
expressions involving variables
Clear enough.
They wrote 2y of a square and say x is equal to 1, which is inappropriate,
because there is no x, y is equal to 5.
If y is equal to 5, this can be recorded
like 2 by 5 per square
And notice, I put brackets there.
I could write this as
2 by 5 per square.
And if you look at the order of operations, gradation
has a higher priority than multiplication.
That is precisely why I automatically put my mind
these braces.
First we will graduate.
That's 25, so we got 2 by 25, which is 50
So the answer to 2b is equal - in a darker color - that
is equal to 50
Let us decide 2d
.
We have given a square minus x, all square.
x is equal to 2, and y equals 1. Well, we only substitute.
Where we see y, we write in his place 1.
So this will become 1 per square x minus square -
Excuse, minus x, not x square.
We put only x there.
Here is where we will replace with 2.
And then all this in a square.
Well 1 of a square is again 1, so it's 1.
1 minus 2 is negative 1.
Then we will have to square up our negative 1,
so this will be equal to positive 1.
And this is equal to 1 Negatively negative is positive.
.
Okay, let's solve 3b
3b.
The next tasks
I will write them in yellow.
Decide the following
expressions involving variables.
All right.
The same idea.
So they give us 4x on 9x per square
Oh, actually I said I'd decide 3b, and I started 3a.
So we start.
We have z of a square on x plus plus x square
on x minus y.
And they tell us that x is equal to 1, y is equal to
negative 2 and z equals 4
Let's first make our replacement.
Thus, z the square is the same thing as - I will write it in
different color - 4 per square on x, 1, plus y, negative 2,
plus x per square, this is 1 per square, on x,
which is 1, minus y.
y is negative 2.
So this will become equal to 4 per square is 16, on 1 plus
negative 2, it's 1 minus 2 - it's just negative 1 - plus
1 per square, which is 1 per 1 minus negative 2.
This is the same as 1 plus 2
That is, 1/3.
So it will be divided into negative 1.
We could record this as equal to negative 16 plus 1/3.
Now - if we want to collect them as fragments, we must
to put a common denominator
Negative 16 is also equal to minus 48 on 3, negative 48 to 3
If you split 48 to 3 you will get 16, and I just
I keep the negative sign.
And then you add to that plus 1/3.
We have a common denominator now, 3.
Negative 48 plus 1 equals negative 47
So our answer is negative 47 on 3.
Task 3d.
.
Such a situation.
x squares minus z squares on xz minus 2x in z minus x.
x is equal to negative 1, z equals 3.
Make our replacements.
This is x square
Which is minus 1 per square
minus z of square, means minus 3 per square
All this on x at z.
x in z is minus 1 by 3, minus 2 by x, x e
negative 1, z minus x, 3 minus x.
x is negative 1 minus x.
Wherever we see x, we put minus 1
This will happen - remember, first count
degrees. Well,
the braces first, then the grading.
So we have a negative 1 per square, that's exactly positive 1.
3 per square, this is positive 9.
And our numerator became 1 minus 9 this is minus 8 or
negative 8.
and then our denominator.
Negative 1 in 3 is negative 3
And then let's calculate our brackets here.
We have 3 minus negative 1, this is exactly the same as
3 plus plus 1.
So here it is 4.
Or our denominator has become negative 3 minus 2 by
negative 1 in 4, this is negative 8
Minus negative 8.
Minus than negative is the same as plus.
Thus, the whole becomes negatively 8 on negative 3 plus 8
negative 3 plus 8 is 5
Or this is negative 8/5, minus 8 on 5.
Okay, let me clear a little room so we can
to see this task well.
Let me clear everything up here
.
These are interesting now.
Task 4: Put brackets in each expression so you get it
true equality.
Charming.
Okay ..
Thus, 4b.
We have 12 divided by 4 plus 10 minus 3 by 3 plus 7
is equal to 11.
Let's see what happens if we just follow the order of order
of operations, and I will calculate in mind because
this will require some experimentation.
Oh, yeah, this 4b, 12 divided by 4 -
yes, this is the task.
So, if we divide 12 to 4 first, we'll get 3
So let me write it in yellow.
If we apply the order of operations, it will be equal to 3
This is going to be 9.
So we will get 3 plus 10, which is 13, minus 9,
13 minus 9 is 4, plus 7
In fact, that seems true.
Let me make sure I thought it right.
3 plus 10 - OK, it seems true.
So we really need only to apply the sequence of operations.
So it looks like a real equation.
If you think 12 divided by 4 plus 10 minus 3 by 3 plus
7, I think it's going true.
Let's confirm.
Let's make sure I do not make a mistake.
12 divided by 4 is 3 plus 10 minus, 3 by 3 is 9, plus 7.
This is equal to 13 minus 9 which is equal to-- all of this
is equal to 13 minus 9, is equal to 4, plus 7 is, actually,
equal to 11.
That was not too bad.
In fact, it was not necessary to place brackets here
make the expression true.
Just follow the order of action.
But putting these braces there, they do it a little
easier to read.
Let's try 4d.
.
12 minus 8 minus 4 minus 5 is equal to minus 8
First, let's see what happens if we apply it
the order of action.
If we apply the order of action directly, we will calculate this
4 at 5 first, which will give us 20 there.
And then we will have 12 minus 8, which is 4.
And then we count 4 minus 20 - No, that's not right
That would give us a negative 16.
So that's not true
So we can not apply the order directly
of actions.
Excuse me, it's minus 8 there.
Let's see what we can do with this.
Let's try some options.
What we will get if we first count 12 minus 8 minus 4 and then multiply
this at 5.
Let's see what we get.
I just experiment with the brackets.
So if we have 8 minus 4, this will be here
8 minus 4 is 4.
And then 4 by 5 will be 20, and then 12 minus 20 -
yes it is.
Let's confirm this
So, I say I will put clamps right there
right there, and let's calculate it.
You will see that 8 minus 4 is 4.
So all this was simplified to 12,
minus 4 by 5.
And we only apply the order of action,
first multiply. That's exactly 20.
And if I wanted to do that very clearly, in fact
I would write it this way.
I would put some more
brackets right.
But the order of operations would tell us this anyway.
Finally, we get 12 minus 20, which is actually minus 8
or negative 8.